If there's one thing I think every day it's--
(Gasp!) I've made a horrible mistake.
Whether I'm hungover and see the drunk text messages that I sent the night before. (Shriek)
Or I ask I guy out to lunch and I get rejected. (Shriek)
Or I write a book called, "So Much I Want to Tell You, Letters to my Little Sister."
and I worry that everyone will hate it when it comes out on June 13th, 2017. Preorder at the link below!
(Ding!)
(Shriek)
There's this cliché saying that you'll regret the things you didn't do, more than the ones that you did
And to that saying, I say
Have you met me? Do you know the sh*t I've done? I am full of regrets.
Oh my God, Anna you were so lit last night!
What?! Really?! Ugh.
Dude, I don't remember anything.
Time to check the Instastory...
(Dramatic sound effect) Oh no.
Oh yes!
Oh no!
Dude.
Check your Twitter.
OH NOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOO
You flirt with Gaby Dunn so much,
like, when are you guys gonna hook up?
I don't know, Gaby.
You tell me... (ding)
But to be honest,
I'm really tired of hating myself.
And like,
Obsessing over everything that I do and say
And telling myself that it's wrong
And that everybody hates me.
'Cause it's like,
I could've probably read four REALLY big books
In the time that I've spent cringing over my own existence.
You know,
I could've been so much more productive;
I could've been writing
Or like, hanging out with friends
Or binging a Netflix series
Instead of just being stuck in my head.
What are you doing today?
Um... well, I have an audition in the afternoon...
And then I have a meeting...
And then I'm gonna spend the rest of the evening
Uh,
Remembering the time that I accidentally
Called my friends nerds
In like, a joking manner
But they kind of took it seriously
And then I hurt their feelings
And then I'm just gonna just, you know marinade in that
Embarrassment and shame for a bit.
... Oh.
Well, did you want to go to dinner?
(Tsk) No, I don't... I can't...
I really have to spend the evening hating myself.
I talked to my friend Mandy the other day,
about how I just feel so self-conscious
and self-aware of my every action,
and she kind of echoed the sentiment that she felt the same as well.
And it feels weird, it's like
Why do I feel like I've reverted into like,
a 15 year old teenager who's just desperate
for the approval of my peers?
Is this normal...?
And I don't what it is...
You know, maybe it's the human condition.
Maybe it's because 30 is around the corner
And this is adulthood's cruel joke that
High school is actually real life.
You think you're gonna leave, but
Nuh uh uh!
You're gonna perpetually be in the state of mind of being a teenager
Where you're analysing every single action that you take in hating yourself
Even though no one really cares.
So, yeah
I'm like, tired of feeling like I've made horrible mistakes.
Because to be honest, horrible mistakes are kind of really fun, right?
Like, bad decisions lead to good stories.
I really believe in that.
And I would rather just approach all of my mistakes
With confidence and like, being comfortable in my own skin
And not second-guessing every decision that do I make even though it goes horribly array.
And unfortunately, there's no real easy fix for this, right?
It's just re-wiring your thought patterns.
So what I have to work on, is every time I revert back into cringing over a past memory,
To catch myself, and be like:
"No! Not gonna do that!"
"Just let it go."
Because... to be honest,
No one's ever gonna dread of that memory except for me.
And I probably shouldn't.
'Cause it's just torturing myself.
I'm Anna Akana.
Stay awesome, Gotham.